[Music]
if you need to deploy
a large number of identical virtual
machines then google cloud's managed
instance groups
is the best way to do that but its auto
scaling feature is what takes it to the
next level
so let's take a look at a configuration
to see what it looks like
so let's start by going over here to the
navigation menu and going down to
compute
engine and then over to instance groups
so what i have on this project is one
managed instance group called web app so
let's click here to go to the overview
page
and we'll see that this manage instance
group has three instances
only so each instance in this instance
group is just an
http application that returns some basic
instance information up here
it also has some built-in functionality
that lets me increase the load on each
instance in the form of cpu utilization
so let's initiate that on each of these
machines
sounds the second one
and the third so now
on each of these instances the
application is consuming more and more
cpu as you can see on the overview page
i have auto scaling enabled on this
manage
instance group let's take a look at the
configuration
so what we have is a regional managed
instance group
distributed across three zones in the
u.s central region
and if you go down here you'll find the
auto scaling configuration
if you have an existing managed instance
group without auto scaling enabled
you'll have instead down here a button
that says configure auto scaling
so i'm going to talk about a few of the
options that you have in the auto
scaling configuration
first you'll want to choose what you
want your auto scaling to be triggered
by
and you can choose from any of these
three metrics cpu utilization load
balancing utilization
and stackdriver monitoring metrics
depending on your use case you can
choose one of these or
a combination by just clicking add new
metric
next you'll want to choose a minimum and
a maximum
i'll set my minimum to three because i
have a regional managed instance group
and i want to make sure i have at least
one instance in each of my three zones
if you know that it takes a while for
your instances to initialize after boot
time
there are three settings that you'll
want to pay attention to
so the first one is the cool down period
so cooldown period is also known as the
application initialization period
it's important because when an
application on an instance is
initializing
the usage might not reflect normal
circumstances
so the auto scaler will not take into
account the usage data from this time
period
when it decides to scale in or out
second
is the scaling controls down here so
scaling controls let you set a limit to
how quickly the auto scaler scales your
instance group down
to avoid any sudden drops in the number
of instances
so this isn't required but it will help
you optimize cost
by avoiding turning down too many
instances too quickly
only to have to wait for new one
supervision immediately after
and finally there's predictive auto
scaling
so predictive auto scaling feeds your
instance groups historical trends
and current load into a machine learning
model so that it can anticipate auto
scale events
so this is going to improve the
availability because instead of scaling
up reactively due to a metric threshold
like cpu
the instance group will scale up in
anticipation
of the load that it predicts will happen
based on real world usage
so if your application takes time to
start up this is going to be
very valuable in helping ensure that
your instance group is ready to handle
an increasing load when it happens
without having to wait too long for
initialization
together predictive auto scaling scaling
controls and an
accurate cooldown period will increase
availability and optimize
spending on resources so if we go back
to our overview page
we'll see that the auto scaler has
already started to provision additional
instances to accommodate the cpu load of
the group
once that load is reduced it'll scale
back according to the scaling controls
that i specified before
that was a super quick look at the auto
scaling configuration of a managed
instance group
when you're using managed instance
groups on google cloud for your
application
its auto scaling is a really useful and
powerful feature
with the right settings and
configuration you can increase your
availability
while reducing costs associated with
compute resources